[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to the Tony
Michaels podcast
the very first two-hour Daily Show
Newton Eastern 11 Central right here on
YouTube Twitter and twitch that's right
now you can view the shitless Roundup
from not just twitch and Twitter but you
can also view it
you can also view it
sorry we're gonna have a few technical
difficulties because we're still trying
to get used to exactly how this is gonna
work but you can view it on YouTube
Twitter and twitch the [__] list Roundup
because we're going to do the [__] list
Roundup today inside the Tony Michaels
podcast right here on YouTube Twitter
twitch and it's going to be every single
weekday every [__] one of them noon
Eastern 11 Central
for two hours
we're gonna do the [__] list Roundup
we're gonna do interviews we're gonna do
the bonehead of the week on Friday I
think Gabe is going to join us today
here in just a bit as we're doing the
shitless Roundup uh we had a we have a
great interview scheduled for this week
and we have not recorded it yet I think
we recorded tomorrow hopefully we'll be
able to
um give you that interview Wednesday or
Thursday we will let you know
speaking of interviews last week we
interviewed Jeremy London
you know the 90s heartthrob of Mall Rats
and I actually posted up on YouTube if
you're on the YouTube channel don't
forget to subscribe but I posted up on
the YouTube channel the interview just
the interview alone with Jeremy London
so you can go over there and take a look
at that also last night we re-aired the
bonehead of the week that we did on
Friday me and Gabe so you can also go
view that on YouTube as well
I think that's what we're gonna do so
what we'll do is we'll just we'll post
the interview separate on YouTube so you
can go watch those but the podcast every
single day every single weekday
Wednesday's noon Eastern 11 Central
right here on YouTube Twitter twitch I
don't know if you guys are out on
Twitter if you're out on Twitch hey MJ
welcome welcome she says welcome [__] em
fam
the [__] family
the [__] them Army
I'm glad that you guys joined me today
on Monday there's a lot of news there's
a lot of news over the weekend several
Clips I want to play uh one from Newt
Gingrich I didn't know this guy was
still alive I'm just kidding I really
knew he was alive but
is he alive on the inside or is it just
the outside is it just a skin suit
on top of a dead body I don't know I'm
just
Newt Gingrich who the [__] gives a [__]
about what this [__] thinks
what this goddamn Nazi thinks and the
seditious [__] that he says
God damn well you know it happens that
way sometimes
so we'll get to that I want to show you
I want to show you uh
I had the booger sugar meltdown of John
Jr he can barely say Joe Biden's name
this is [__] hilarious like like you
know everyone wants to feel sorry for
this [__] because he's down in a
downward spiral here but [__] this guy
[__] this guy you know [__] him
he's his business is about to be [__]
chopped apart with an ax by Tish by Tish
James and the New York attorney
general's office and they're gonna have
to [__] go in and testify on this
civil case that is prop that is probably
going to break up their company just
like she did Trump University and the uh
the Trump Foundation where they were
[__] laundering money through what
what they they said was a charity [__]
that [__]
oh man this is going to be fantastic
Mayo says exactly look at look at Mayo's
on Twitch MJ's on YouTube we got it
going today we have got it going today
MJ says [__] them Army let's go with
that all right MJ we'll go with that the
[__] them Army I'm fine with it I'm fine
with it whatever you guys want to call
yourselves
just hashtag that [__] or something I
don't know I don't know
as long as long as you stay pissed and
go [__] vote that's all I give a [__]
about that's all I care that's all I
care so let's get into this very first
two hour episode of the Tony Michaels
pad podcast with the [__] list Roundup
because Putin's puppies
in the Republican Party want to placate
to him let's start the countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
part of the show I think that's gonna be
most of the show today we're just gonna
there's a lot of [__] to round up over
the weekend I think I think Mondays will
actually be mostly mostly mostly mostly
the [__] list Roundup because we have to
round up everything from [__] Friday
night Saturday and Sunday hell we may
have to go all the way into Tuesday with
the [__] list Roundup from the weekend
some of these days Jesus [__] Christ
these [__] idiots
um the ship that Newt Gingrich says um
yeah we we had the we had the anti-anti
Mandate rally in in Washington you guys
seen this [__]
um uh Bobby Kennedy Jr I guess said
something he invoked the Holocaust like
four or five times like what the [__]
are you doing
you dumb [__] listen this this
Holocaust [__] I think is gonna really
um affect this you know them keep saying
it's the Holocaust and stuff this is
really this is really ignorant [__] but
it really is gonna hurt them in the long
run
um their movement but we'll get into
that
um we also what else we get on the [__]
list we got Sarah Palin of course uh
there's a lawsuit with New York Times
that's gonna happen um affirmative
affirmative action
is trending or was trending this morning
I don't know what for I didn't actually
go into thread but I thought it was
probably going to be relevant you also
see all the Eastern Europe NATO Putin
Russian uh gonna uh you know invade
Ukraine that's a big big story this
morning we're gonna see what's gonna
happen with that
um as Putin test Joe Biden
um obviously Putin is a little upset
that we broke up with his [__]
girlfriend back in 2020 during the
election his girlfriend's a little upset
too I hear I hear he's [__] pissed
uh still crying down at [__]
Mar-A-Lago
but we also we also want to talk about
the Julian Assange uh news I guess he
has won his uh right to appeal to the UK
Supreme Court
for his extradition to the United States
so we'll get into that thread as well as
well we'll go there we'll go there but
let's let's get into the [__] list
Roundup here let's start with the uh the
pro the profiles and the timelines the
Tweety tweets and the trendy Trends hey
look here this is a good clip uh from
the um the interview we did with Sarah
Jeremy London Jeremy London from
Mallrats again the interview is over on
YouTube all you gotta do is click that
link on this video and it'll take you
right to the uh I think it takes you to
the the podcast episode or the interview
one or the other but it's over on
YouTube and and if you're on YouTube
right now click the like button and do
the [__] and whatever you know I'm
supposed to say that you're supposed to
do they say oh if you're on YouTube you
got to tell them to click the [__] and
click the bike button and the well yeah
so whatever I'm supposed to say to get
you to do the Subscribe thing and all
that pretend I said that okay let's get
down into it uh let's see
this morning I tweeted uh Putin seems
upset we broke up with his girlfriend in
2020 you know I think I think Putin is
very
very upset he's challenging Biden here
um here's angry staffer with this um
with this Don Jr video maybe we should
just go ahead and play this Don Jr video
right off the top why the [__] not
um Angry Stamper says it's a shame
nobody cares about Junior because he
needs an interview intervention stat
this guy is [__] off the rails
because he's doing rails like every
[__] day like he just can't help
himself here
he is totally [__] uncapable
of handling whatever it is that he's
handling you know his entire [__]
business their money laundering machine
being smashed up with an ax there's all
kinds of [__] going on with Don Jr
uh mystery Solomon posted this is John
Jr is on another Bender the pressure
must be getting to him he's drained
slurred unnatural speech is clearly
drug-fueled
I I don't I think it's a little more
than [__] drugs but there's a lot of
[__] going on here drugs alcohol uh
stress anxiety
um fear there's there's a lot of factors
in this [__] thing well let's let's
watch this crazy [__] idiot and of
course this this has got 2.3 million
views and I think does he post his [__]
on Instagram where does he post this
[__] or on Facebook where does this
[__] post this you know they
always complain about oh it's all
left-wing [__] and they won't let me
post anything
and he posted on wherever the [__] he's
where the [__] he's live streaming this
stupid [__] at and then and then what he
does then what he does is he oh they
won't let it on Twitter [__] bring
that [__] on Twitter we want this [__]
on Twitter live stream that [__]
straight on Twitter you dumb [__] I
wanna I wanna watch your dumb ass
meltdown this is what the country's been
[__] waiting for we've been waiting
for this moment let's do it
is the jump item in the same room as
someone he might uh let one rip
what you can't put Joe Biden in the same
room as someone he might let one rent is
this the fart thing that they're [__]
still obsessed with
that he farted
like like this like like [__] Trump's
never farted this this guy [__]
gobbles up Big Macs all the time
and you think we're [__] fooled that
you can't you can't
of course Trump shits his diapers all
the time what the [__] are you talking
about male says he's high as [__] yeah
he's high as [__] holy [__] this guy's
this guy is I don't I don't know I don't
know exactly what he's taking you know
booger sugar is always probably a good
guess
but this [__] is way on way more
than just [__] Coke way [__] more
than just [__] Coke this is way more
than a Coke Bender way [__] more
let's listen to this you'll know what I
mean guys guys Joe Biden
Japan
what the German jib
[Laughter]
uh Joe Biden is your president [__] is
what stands between us God this [__]
guy
and a nuclear-capable China
Joe Biden is the guy they're gonna call
at three in the morning because he's the
president you dumb [__]
yeah yeah that's that's because eight
million more of us said we definitely
want that Joe Biden in charge of the
nuclear weapons over your [__] dumb
ass dad
the one that won't answer your phone
calls you got to text Mark Meadows on
Jan six to get get a message to him you
know he'd take Ibaka's calls but he
won't take your calls what's this [__]
on the shelf behind him
what is this stuff
is that is that booze up there does he
got booze on the Shelf is that what he's
drinking I don't know what is that up
there
that can't be [__] like like grape
juice or some [__] right and he's got
all these [__] pictures what is all
this [__] you know he used to stand in
front of his is like his gun background
right he used to have a background with
like like little bitty pistols hanging
all over the wall you know making him
look cool and [__] now he's now he's got
he's in front of the bookshelf let's
continue
if
there's a serious crisis
with Russia because you know can't put
Joe bite in the same room as someone he
might uh let one rip this guy guys Joe
Joe Ben
oh my God what a [__] idiot okay
oh oh here uh Gabe pointed out something
here from Patriot dicks
now let's see what this is I think it's
uh I think he says he he Jeb bushed
himself you guys remember back in 2016
Jeb Bush Jeb Bush was running for uh
president United States and he was
talking before a crowd I think you guys
remember this [__]
he was talking before a crowd oh good
morning Yoda Yoda's here
Eddie Eddie MJ says probably urine you
talking about the bottle on the
bookshelf yeah it might it might it
might be urine it's full of blood so
it's probably his urine
um but you guys remember this moment
back in um 2016 when Jeb Bush was
talking to a crowd of people it's like a
town hall or some [__] right and uh he
says
he says something you know he thought
was really prolific right I mean just
totally prolific and everyone should
stand up and give him a standing ovation
and no one [__] said a peep like the
Crickets in the room was deafening and
he says please clap and they're like oh
oh yeah that's oh yeah yeah and they
start clapping so I think that's what
what Gabe is saying here I haven't I
haven't seen
uh exactly but let's let's watch here
exactly what happens
no one's clapping for him oh yeah yeah
[Music]
please clap please please clap oh please
please clap what a [__] dummy oh my
God Patriot takes where did you get this
video you must be following I don't know
how Patriot dicks does this follows all
these son of a [__] and gets all to
get all this [__] and you know how much
[__] you'd have to sift through to get
this [__] [__] [__] ridiculous
um Caitlyn says oh loser Caitlyn
aggressive Progressive [__]
you changed your handle there Caitlyn
uh
wow he's so cracked out MJ must be
talking about uh uh don Jr I don't know
maybe he's talking about Donnie daddy
Donnie here
um
but it is pathetic that he's got it he's
got a [__] please clap please clap
let's see what else we get
um
oh Midas Touch has got a new video I
don't know if you guys want to watch
this video from Midas Touch
um it's about five and a half minutes we
can watch it if you want I I'm I'm not
opposed to playing it um I I watched it
the other night it is a really good
video it kind of breaks down the coup
and the coup that to come and what they
want to do I mean they're really trying
hard to have another coup for sure for
sure I mean we can watch this video if
you want
um we can uh give them credit here maybe
we'll watch part of it we'll watch part
of it maybe we'll make it through let's
let's uh
go back
make this big
let's watch this oh I gotta walk down to
the Capitol because you'll never take
back our country with weakness it All
Began before January 6 2021
we can now project that former Vice
President Joe Biden has been elected
president of the United States as Joe
Biden's Victory became apparent the GOP
hatched a criminal plot to overturn the
election results we were getting ready
to win this election frankly we did win
this election
the plan disrupt the certification
process claim fraud submit fake electors
and appoint Donald Trump president
against the will of the people there
will be a smooth transition to a second
Trump Administration first they flood
the courts with frivolous lawsuits
hoping for a quid pro quo from Trump
appointees the Dominion voting systems
were created in billions in Venezuela at
the direction of Hugo Chavez they lose
nearly all of the 62 cases they filed
an executive order is prepared for
Donald Trump's signature to have the
military seize all voting machines we
could take military capabilities and he
could place them in those States and
basically rerun an election at each of
those States martial law has been
instituted 64 times Donald Trump
instills lackeys in the Department of
Defense and doj like cash Patel Jeffrey
Clark and Chris Miller president Trump
is purging the top ranks of the Pentagon
after firing defense secretary Mark
esper replacing officials with White
House loyalists for this lame duck
period of his presidency and why are
they being installed after Trump's
defeat
seven states Forge electoral
certificates and send them to the
National Archives so this video I don't
mean to cut it off here but this video
is doing a good job of uh of laying out
the evidence that we're seeing that's
coming out a little by little in the
public and you gotta understand that's
exactly what the January 6th select
committee wants so the Republicans
didn't want a non-political
investigation body like a 911 style
commission they didn't want that they
wanted to play politics with this
because they you know they're yelling
and screaming like Donald Trump and all
these Donald Trump Jr and Kevin McCarthy
um oh it's all political and it's a
political Witch Hunt and all this
[__] and you know they're uncovering
evidence of you people trying to
overturn the Constitution of the United
States yeah it's okay okay a Witch Hunt
so who's the [__] witch but here's
the thing it's that the January 6th
select committee is trying to tell a
story by uh a process of going little by
little through this process of is
issuing subpoenas getting depositions
and laying out the process for some of
the public hearings that should be
started
and that's what the American people need
is little by little get the story told
them because if they just dumping in our
[__] lamps Jesus Christ our new cycle
is no longer than five [__] seconds
but Midas Touch does a really good job
of laying out not just not just what we
know has happened but also what the
January 6th select committee has started
to unveil and not only that but the
Department of Justice with some of these
seditious conspiracy charges and other
charges and other plea deals that have
made in federal court as fake electors
attempt to break into state capitals
seven states have chosen a slate of
electors for both Joe Biden and
president Trump in those states there
has been an alternate slate of electors
voted upon we can direct that the
ultimate slate of electors be certified
we're fixing to overturn the results of
the election in multiple States Attorney
John Eastman drafts a legal blueprint
detailing how vice president Pence can
evade the law and count these fake
electors instead
the Department of Justice drafts letters
to swing States falsely claiming that
there was election fraud in an attempt
to throw the Real Results into question
Clark reportedly drafted a letter to
Georgia State legislators that
incorrectly said doj was investigating
accusations of voter fraud in the state
and that Georgia officials should
invalidate Biden's win I just want to
find 11
780 votes and Republicans hit the
airwaves to fire up their base and
spread the big lie and it's enough
object in that state elect those State
selectors don't get counted in the final
vote there are a number of states that
have come into question here when the
process is complete there'll be elector
selected you can actually have alternate
electors you throw out the certification
and let the house decide and that and
that's the whole plan behind Mike Pence
and why they wanted to hang him in the
front of the capitol
this is it this is why they wanted to
hang Mike Pence in front of the Capitol
because he wouldn't go along with this
[__] nonsense that that you could
have fraudulent electors that the states
didn't certify and that he could just he
could just make those the electors on
the floor of the house and make Donald
Trump the [__] president United
States well this is the case folks if
this is the case right we got we gotta
we got a midterm coming up here that is
we need to focus highly on and the
reason why is because if you think they
weren't attempting a coup here you
imagine what kind of coup they're going
to try to attempt after 2022 and up in
the lead up to 2024. but here's the
thing in 2024
um the person who's going to preside no
matter who wins that election no matter
who wins the election in 2024
as long as Kamala Harris
the vice president United States is
still seated in that office right
which assuming she will be
but Kamala Harris
in 2025 and January of 2025 regardless
of who wins regardless of who wins what
the right is telling us the left
is that all we have to do all we have to
do to win an election is make sure
that we cheat that's what they're saying
I mean that's what they tried to do not
not only did they try to uh develop
fraudulent electors which it is uh still
unclear to me at this point these
fraudulent electors who signed on to
this uh not just not just the
[__] that plan this out Ruby
Giuliani Sidney Powell Jenna Ellis
um some of these others who were
involved in going to these states and
trying trying to get these fraudulent
electors out front you remember you
remember you remember the hearing in
Michigan when Rudy Giuliani [__] crop
dusted Jenna Ellis right there in the
goddamn Committee hearing you know
farted over right and ain't named Don
Junior's complaining about Joe
bidenvarten come on he must have
experience with old Rudy
but here's the thing they weren't going
to those States they weren't going to
those States uh for voting machines and
all this garbage they were going to
recruit fraudulent electors
and so I want to know I want to know
which jurisdiction uh that that is a
crime of because it seems like a lot of
the attorney generals in these states
are very interested in not only who
planned these fraudulent electors but
who who wanted to be the fraudulent
electors there will be a lot of things
happening between now and the 20th of
January a lot of things president
Trump's presence his first terms ending
with action and his second term is going
to start with a bank
key Trump officials meet at the Willard
Hotel on January 5th to plot their
takeover
as white nationalist groups like The
Proud boys and Oath Keepers stand back
and stand by we'll be inside DC will
also be on the outside of DC armed
prepared to go in if the president
so here here is the the the the eye
patch guy from Texas the the
coup pirate as it were
um I guess I guess Stewart Rhodes did
you guys know this this [__] the
reason why he lost his eye and wears an
eye patch
is he shot his own eye out
I'm not kidding you that's
he shot his own eye out
not like trying to attempt suicide no
nothing like that it it was it was like
a shooting range accident or some [__]
and this is who they had in charge of
stockpiling weapons and make sure I mean
you heard him say it [__] you heard him
say it if if anything goes down we'll
come across to all president Trump has
to do is say the word
give me a [__] break on January 6th
Donald Trump tweets out his demands that
the fraudulent electors be counted whips
his army of supporters into a frenzy
likes the match
[Applause]
[Music]
so go home we love you you're very
special the coup fails but Republicans
use the chaos they created as pretext to
change voting laws across the country
Republican lawmakers and at least 43 and
that's because they want the next coup
they want to set up the next goddamn
coup
K1 says amateurs
[__] suck oh it sucks to suck doesn't
it you can't even can't even get a coup
right no it happens
[Laughter]
even Hitler failed his first Q attempt
three states are considering more than
250 proposed bills that would make it
harder to vote and then still partisan
vote counters who promise to throw away
votes they don't like in future
elections it would be a lot sharper the
next time when it comes to counting the
vote is a famous statement sometimes the
vote counter is more important than the
candidate and we can't let that ever
ever happen again they have to get
tougher and smarter this is a coup in
plain sight
history will judge where we stand in
this moment
which side are you on
I mean they always claim to be you know
to be uh pro-democracy and for the
Constitution
here they are it's very obvious it's
very obvious that they wanted to [__]
all over
the [__] the [__] Constitution of
the United States they wanted to rip it
up
and destroy it
um
very very great video by Midas Touch of
laying out exactly what is happening
with the January 6 select committee and
I think um Brett did a fantastic the
Midas brother might as Dutch Brothers
the my zealous Brothers the defend eggs
jug but uh it's you know even at the end
the credits there Brett wrote and
directed and did the film we all know we
all know who over at Midas statue does
the if he does the video so it's a great
job boys but uh fantastic job Brett on
this video laying it out in a way that
people can watch and it's got got almost
a million views you guys should go
retweet this thing we need to get this
thing up to two or three million views
um because it does really lay out
exactly what the January 6 select
committee is trying to tell us out in
the open and trying to tell that story
because that's really what they're
trying to do with a lot of these drops
and leaks and
and things is trying to tell that story
um and and
Princess
um we the people she brought this to my
attention so uh thanks thanks for
bringing that to my attention
featured on the [__] let's round up if
you read it you get credit all right
let's move on
um oh what is this wait a second wait a
second wait a second what is this this
breaking footage from Eric Eric Trump's
pleading the 15th quote unquote
uh leak footage from Eric's six hour
deposition what is this what is this
this is this is Eric Trump's deposition
you guys know the story that uh Eric
Trump went into a deposition with the
attorney general the New York and uh he
played the fifth 500 times 500 times
this guy played the fifth now what that
means is that 500 times he was able he
was able to self-incriminate himself and
he chose not to five
100 times his attorney's like um no no
plead the fifth plead the fifth but of
course we all know that Eric Trump
probably has the least amount of brain
cells of all them which is really
surprising I mean seeing the video from
Don Jr that we just watched a bit ago it
is very [__] surprising that Eric
Trump can manage to conjure up more
brain cells or less brain cells than his
[__] cokehead brother
I mean these are things that happen
so let's um let's take a look at this
here
let's begin the deposition can you say
your first and last name your first and
last name oh you want my name no I plead
the 15th wait the 15 to 10 is about
racial equality and voting no no that's
not the one I want no they're called
attendance it's from the constipation
you know the one that Nicholas Cage
stole I had the answer written on my
hand but now it's all smeared because
it's all sweaty give me a second I'll
get it can you read what this says I I
know it's not the first or the second
attendant Mr lawyer man is my dad bad at
me can you just tell me what Ivanka and
Junior said I'll say the same thing they
said I was the genius behind everything
they're right I am a genius and I
thought of everything oh um can I get
some more OJ let's begin the deposition
Always On Target Caitlyn says he never
misses Gabe never misses MJ loves Gabe
yeah you know it happens over here that
that we have a great executive producer
that not only can exactly produce but he
can bump out these [__] videos is and
really clown these son of a [__]
um it's fantastic it's fantastic so uh I
think I think Gabe is supposed to join
us here soon so maybe we'll ask him
we'll come back and ask him some
questions about this video
um but um
maybe we'll get some more leaked footage
of Eric Trump's uh deposition maybe
maybe once Donald Trump hey there you go
maybe once Donald Trump and uh Ivanka
and Eric uh maybe even Jared testifying
deposition I'm not sure who's on the
list for uh the the Attorney General of
New York kiss James but maybe we'll get
some League footage from them as well
okay let's see here what else do we get
[Music]
oh here's the Newt Gingrich video
uh from over the weekend of course on
[__] uh fake news our Fox News excuse
me I don't even know why the [__] we
gotta call them news anymore we know
they're not [__] news
um I said if you're still sitting around
wondering what the new Bannon Coupe plan
is Newt Gingrich LARPing for sloppy
Steve
Ron had posted this video says Newt
Gingrich says this morning the people
serving on the j6 committee
are gonna go to jail they're gonna go to
jail if Republicans take over Congress
after the next election let's listen to
what this [__] email this old nasty
sweaty ball sack has to say let's listen
uh you're gonna have a republican
majority in the house and Republican
majority in the Senate and all these
people who've been so tough and so mean
and so nasty are going to be delivered
subpoenas for every document every
conversation every tweet about one email
uh because I think it's clear that this
these are people who are literally just
running over the law pursuing innocent
people causing them to spend thousands
and thousands of dollars in legal fees
for no justification and it's basically
a Lynch Mob and unfortunately the
Attorney General the United States has
joined that Lynch Mob and is totally
misusing the FBI and I think when you
have a republican Congress this is all
going to come crashing down and the
wolves are going to find out that
they're now sheep and they're the ones
who are in fact gonna I think for face a
real risk of jail for the kind of laws
that are breaking
oh my God
the projection is just too [__] much
hey look who we got here
um we just we just saw a video from a
guy it kind of looks like you ding dong
what yeah ding dong yeah
what video what video was that
um well there was a video of Eric Trump
and he kind of looks like you though I
don't know
um meeting the 15th he didn't know what
the fifth is or the 14th or 15th he's
not real sure yeah yeah yeah
that was not me that was not
yeah
so what do you think about old Newt here
talking about that did you did you watch
his clip yeah I saw it
the the whole like
we're gonna go after you guys it's just
like
it reminds me it's um
of like when kids on the schoolyard is
like you're right it's like no you're it
you're it you're it's like no tag backs
like it's just that what it is it's like
I remember your glue right you know I
mean hey the Democrats have actual proof
and evidence that they've been
presenting and to show you that oh look
you guys did try to attempt a coup and
then they go no no no no no no see
that's not that's not what happened and
then you know through some projection
revisionism like whatever they try to
just place it back on the Democrats and
I mean this is not the first time I've
heard something like this before I
forget who mentioned this maybe a few
weeks ago and they said basically if
Republicans get power in in the house
they're going to then flip the uh
uh uh the focus and Target Democrats
instead which is like for what for uh
for uncovering a coup I mean here
Caitlyn says Kansas these people that
have been so tough so mean so nasty
about a [__] coup like you like yeah
yeah the [__] Democrats are [__]
pissed you tried to overthrow the
Constitution of the United States yeah
they're a little pissed off and there's
a couple Republicans too yeah only a
couple it just sound like what I don't
know if there's any I mean there clearly
is no ground but I think that the thing
that they were pushing against was like
oh the 2022 message for Republicans is
Revenge like Revenge because they were
so mean to us and they were they said
that we were part of this coup and it's
like well I mean if there's smoke
there's fire like you know what you know
what here's the thing I I I hear Alpha
cucks love love revenge porn oh maybe so
maybe that's what this that's what this
[__] is is like coup revenge porn type
stuff yeah they they turn the Gen 6
committee into a bunch of Republicans
trying to try you tried to stop our coup
and then what you tried to do is you
tried to investigate our coup and then
not only that when we committed federal
crimes like seditious conspiracy you
tried to put us into prison you son of a
[__] like what are you talking about
it's it is there's there's nothing that
they have that they could pivot and do a
180 to be like oh look the Democrats
were doing this illegal thing or they
were holding illegal Courts for the
committee you know it's like no uh right
also it's like
it's like there there have been other
Representatives slash aides that have
come forward with information that have
only bolstered the argument like or or
bolster to validate the fact that the
banner is like Republicans or a key
group of Republicans plotted against uh
what we had done as a fair and safe
election to put their interest ahead of
everyone else's right ahead of 81
million people
well you know that's that's the thing
that I've been saying is
they're not trying to overturn Joe
Biden's election they're trying to
overturn our election it's our [__]
vote it's our election and that's the
craziest part about the [__] timeline
that we live in when these people are
like Newt Gingrich saying what he's
saying here is like we're gonna win back
the house and we're going to win back
the Senate and then we're really and
when we do that we're gonna like not
like we're gonna make sure that people
can vote and the elections are fair and
free and fair and that everyone has
their vote counted that way this never
happened nope nope we're gonna make sure
to go after our political enemies and
jail them right like holy [__] yeah
you're looking you're looking kind of
like a bit of a dictatorship you know
right right authoritarianism yeah right
right it's like oh Kim Jong-un you know
Kim Jong-un Kim Jong-un no I I actually
I I tweeted is Newt Gingrich is still
alive of course I knew he's still alive
but look at this guy does he look alive
to you I mean I'm just saying I mean you
ever you ever you ever remember the
movie Men in Black all those years ago
yeah the the the Cockroach what's the
actor's name that played oh uh Vincent
um yes he's the guy that played um
um private pile right on um right yeah
Vincent D'Onofrio yes yes yes and
there's the one scene where he goes in
the house and he drinks the sugar water
right yeah sugar sugar water more sugar
put more in there and then she's like
Edgar your your skin is hanging little
he rips back yeah he's [__] man
that's Newt Gingrich that's why I
questioned if he was alive I don't know
his skin looks a little [__] loose I
mean these These Old Republican ball sex
I mean that's what they end up looking
like like Trump
because I played the video earlier where
the let's clap Donald Trump let's clap
moment down at Mar-A-Lago that you had
posted all right I think Patriot takes
posted you had retweeted this right
right yeah I I also want to put out
there that's like the only time that
Newt Gingrich Newt Gingrich has
um been given
a a collective like oh that's that's
great you know is when and you know some
people might remember this is when Chris
Farley went
and did an impression of him in uh
uh uh
in in a committee right and he came in
and and did a whole impression and that
was probably the only moment when Newt
Gingrich across the aisle
has been a likable character I mean this
is like what 95 he went out there and
did that the one time in his right the
one time did a whole bit made fun you
know everyone's like oh this is great
blah blah you know
a lot of people a lot of people forget
he was the speaker of the house and he
had to step down from his seat of
Congress and the speaker of the house
because the [__] lied in
Congress right like a lot of people
forget that like and here's the
[__] that they got on TV gonna
go after [__] other Congress people
investigating what is members of the
Congress because you [__] tried to
attempt a Cheeto dust kangaroo cool what
do you want what the [__] do you want
them to do about it you're the one that
was out there trying to [__] bang up
the Constitution and wipe your ass with
it uh Mayo says Newt Gingrich can [__]
off
100 always always straight
right straight to the point Mayo she's
not [__] around no absolutely no
[__] to give Mayo has no that's why
that's why she's one of our favorites
here thank you Mayo for your your very
very articulate
um statement about Newt Gingrich there I
agree 100 uh let's see now you've seen
the Don Jr video oh yeah uh there may or
may not be a video I gotta look through
the uh here we go there there may be
more footage there may be more there may
be more footage I mean uh uh and I you
know for the sake of my eyes I might
have to just use his footage you know
take a break because I have another Don
Jr sketch that I have written all right
so tell us tell us about it because
everyone wonders about they always
comment about the eyes tell tell the
audience how how you achieve the John
Don Jr look
method acting
meth yes no meth meth and it's meth and
acting meth and acting yeah yeah meth
and acting uh so people are sharing this
29 second clip but there is like what I
found last night oh yeah yeah there's a
long one um is uh you got that one
somewhere because I'll play that
[__] we will play that oh did
you see this by uh Paulie why we're
talking about the trumps after uh
phenomenal success she had selling her
farts in a jar Ivanka trunk expands her
product line what what what it Gabe
what's a queen what's a can you explain
to the audience what a queef is assure
yeah it's uh uh what kind of fart is a
queef where does the where does the
queef come from Gabe okay well if we
look on the diagram uh right okay um
imagine this is a right a woman's
private area Okay private you mean air
comes out you mean a vagina you mean
yeah yeah well I've got I've got little
innocent ears so oh okay okay well
basically it's air you know that comes
out of there I don't want to get into
the health class uh explanation oh okay
so you don't you don't wanna I'm sure
our audience knows much more than you
right yeah no like I said I mean I'm I'm
innocent I don't know okay well I don't
I don't know I'm I'm a guy so I don't
know I don't know um exactly you know
exactly how this works but apparently um
Paulie found a a great you know
advertisement here for ivanka's queefs
apparently so okay yeah
I don't know maybe
well here's the thing it's four and a
half minutes yeah let's do it all right
I'm good let's well I mean we can fast
forward we can rewind it oh yeah yeah
we'll do that I'm I'm down to to [__]
with this guy
um you send the link here all right now
I got it up
oh you got it you got it going okay well
yeah boom add it in
it's there
a message
guys Joe Biden is at it again
ah
reading the instructions from the
teleprompter and not being able to
decipher
what's the quote and what's the message
what the [__] is he talking about dude
nobody knows just watch like he's just
like like this is coked out word salad
type [__] like he's got and what's funny
is he's like he can't read from
telepromber like I don't read from
Michelle or Robert because it's a good
idea what the [__] yeah dude he's
definitely got uh he did it again
earlier this week good job United stake
of America what at least that's what it
sounded like to me
he waved like a little child to Vladimir
Putin uh
in their meeting oh here's here's the
family that [__] gets on their knees
and grovels to poop right that I I
remember I'm old enough to remember a
text message that Don Jr put on himself
that said oh Russia's Got dirt on
Hillary we love that yeah we love Russia
like what the [__] get out of here with
that [__] virtual meeting is you know
can't put Joe Biden in the same room
with someone you might uh let one rip
like this you think because you know
everyone says he's got like these cute
cards and [__] that he looks at right
I've never heard that but that might
Inspire something no no I think he's got
cute Carson he looks at so you think
like is this big poster board with just
like your bag
Japan
I think just Kimberly guilfoyle's
holding the cue card and she's like
really bad in and then he's like paused
and she's like oh oops
China
that's where it just because she's she's
got him out of orders right right right
oh [__] this guy this is him this is him
wishing he was like on a late night talk
show or like Saturday Night Live and
they're like all right throw the cue
cards oh my God if
there's a serious crisis yeah
with Russia right the guy that can't
tell when he's supposed to stop reading
the instructions he's like Ron Burgundy
but with the real role right you put it
on the teleprompter Joe will read it
and it's not like he's new to this it's
not like he hasn't spent his life doing
this you know half the century in the
United States Senate he still can't tell
check this out see for yourself
of this Bob Dole which is like if you
want to I cannot pretend that I have not
been a loyal champion of my party
but I've always served my country best
so so this is at Bob Dole's funeral yep
yeah yeah and and the president United
States is speaking right and so this is
uh don Jr saying Joe Biden let's learn
his words and mixing up stuff and you
know whatever he's talking about and
he's trying to use it as an example of
uh you know it's like oh well you know
the man does have a stutter and he's
worked over that but you know let's I
guess I've never heard anyone speak in
cursive before but here we are
logical says we really listening to Mr
Coke
oh we're trying to tell the [__]
jokes
you lay off the jokes jokes trying to
tell the problem oh my God now Yoda says
my ass off laughing I am oh my god let's
let's see let's see what someone who uh
is articulate has to say here and then
let's see what the dump Buck has to say
about it after when I did it so first
and foremost
as an American
or a prioritized principles over party
Humanity over a personal Legacy
we do that we accomplish far more as a
nation
by Leading with shared faith in each
other
at its best trying to show Biden he went
on to say that he can he can speak
a source of comfort and crisis because
the thing is here like if you actually
uh take a step back like and you know
we're [__] making fun of this but you
really step back and you look at the
room that Biden's in and he's speaking
in the reason why he's speaking so
slowly is that room Echoes like a
[__] right like it echoes like a
[__] and when someone's speaking
and they have that [__] Echo you know
like they want to go slow to make sure
it's not only that but like he's he's
miked up and that mic is like rejecting
within that like the Acoustics of that
hall right right and and the only reason
why they're doing it there isn't because
of Acoustics is because of it's Bob Dole
and you know that's that's where they
wanted to have it on Capitol Hill where
they want to have honor his funeral not
only that Joe Biden actually knew Bob
Dole right he actually knew him uh
rather you agree with him don't agree
with him whatever you know you like him
don't like him they [__] knew each
other personally like they served in the
Senate together for years
all right let's let's fast forward
because I I get what he's trying to say
here is that Joe Biden's talking slow
but Don Junior obviously doesn't [__]
have a clue why Let's uh let's
then the message said and
a message
so in watching that in seeing it all
these times
do you feel comfortable
with this being the man who's going to
get the call where he will have to make
sure you can possibly the lives of your
family and your children and your loved
ones I sure as hell am not confident
that that's why we vote that's why eight
million more people voted for him
instead of your [__] stupid ass dad
right that's the exact reason right
there what you just said you dumb [__]
like you run head right burst into the
point oh he just keeps going it's like a
you know cartoon where it's like the you
know Wiley Coyote runs through the fake
wall and just like keeps going just
[__] Nails it let's let's see
and what's the message
uh you did it again earlier this week
for family and your children and your
loved ones because I sure as hell am not
confident that this guy is capable of
making even basic decisions on his own
oh we've seen it guys
with anyone else imagine it was a
conservative imagine it was your father
they'd be talking about the 25th
Amendment if we're talking about this
2020 elections oh my God the projection
just they can't stop yeah they're like
imagine if this was a conservative
imagine they were discussed in the 20s
imagine if we were still bringing up
Hillary you are you're doing all of that
you're doing all of that stuff imagine
if we were trying to tell you and guess
late and say this and say that yeah you
are you literally are what are you what
do you think oh my God like and he runs
again he runs straight through the
[__] brick wall over here he's like
wow perfect pause we'll probably stop
I'm dead Junior you know I mean like it
would be better if he would have been
like imagine for a second if there was a
Carnival Barker with really shitty hair
and a tan sprayed skin and he couldn't
walk down a ramp and the entire country
would try to take him here like oh my
god really what the [__] are you he's on
something and it ain't good all right
let's go back to the trendy Trends and
the Tweety tweets let's go so basically
what I was saying earlier is I uh uh
there I'm going to try to work in a
video probably a FaceTime call I would
imagine oh okay who's who's FaceTiming
who here uh well I
Don ends up always finding a way to to
FaceTime me so oh okay yeah okay
where he's facetimed you before yeah
yeah he's done it before right like he
called me when there was the
when there was the fight there it was
UFC fight and some you know so this is
this is when when they were commenting
on the fight is that yeah yeah this was
uh I think it was the night before he
was like pitching for people to listen
to the fight which also the fight was
over in like 30 seconds or whatever okay
uh um but he's called me before you know
Rue Giuliani has my number Don Jr has my
number so are you like Walker has my
therapist or something now Christian
Walker is technically is your roommate
on the internet yeah right yeah yeah no
he's my roommate yeah oh okay okay yeah
we share the same place uh he doesn't
pay rent his dad pays his rent you know
okay okay yeah yeah but there's a lot of
shenanigans that go on on the uh yeah
the roommate content yeah yeah I've got
more I got more videos of those coming
up soon oh okay good good good good I
know I know he's been he was in the news
last week because he was on the San
Abi's uh uh twitch stream right yeah
yeah and they were talking about
transphobia and [__] and of course he
was getting dunked in the trash can yep
um but uh because we talked about that
on the bone end of the week speaking of
that yeah people watch that episode go
to subscribe to the YouTube channel
don't forget and then you can go watch
the uh the US me and Gabe talk about
bone of the week we were talking about
the transphobia and Alpha cucks and
Caitlyn Jenner being a [__]
ridiculous person okay
um so the Tweety tweets and training
Trends here have you heard the news in
Eastern Europe
um about World War III yeah so NATO
sends more ships fighter jets to Eastern
Europe as Russian masses troops on
Ukrainian borders so I mean my my view
of this is is that
um Putin obviously is trying to test the
president of the United States to see
how far he's willing to take this right
um now it doesn't it doesn't appear that
there is not going to be some sort of
conflict
and and of course the Republican party
is trying to really make sure that they
oh they want it to happen oh [__] yeah
well and they they want us to preempt
Putin so he can say see see what they
play right into the hands of this
[__] right you know they're
there the Republicans want everything
that goes against the Democrats to
happen even if it means that they
themselves will die right they want
coveted to spread because it means that
it'll look bad on Biden they want the
economy to crash because it looks bad on
Biden they want World War or three
because it'll look bad on Biden they
literally will do anything they can to
go against the self-interest or the best
interest of the country in terms of our
well-being he'll just say or they will
just say [__] it we want as much damage
as can happen to show or to prove to
anyone else that Joe Biden is the [__]
up that we are right like logical
logicals you know you know they say
right here they said owning the lips via
disseminating everything
it's exactly what it is right like we
are collateral damage to the Republican
party they don't care who you are where
you are what you are I mean maybe if you
have money but other than that they just
don't care as long as it owns the lives
and and shows that Biden is is terrible
or whatever they want like that's all
they carry and really and really what
Putin wants here and um there's actually
a really good uh Kitchen Round that that
politics girl did and I I want to play
that for the audience today I think it's
important for them to see that because
she really breaks it down
um in just a few minutes of exactly
what's happening but but really what
Putin wants here is he wants he wants to
show the world that democracy is the
enemy right he wants to show them that
democracy is the aggressor uh Alexander
vinman here deterrence requires
capabilities and attempt a deployment
deployment east of Europe signals both
um he's responding to
uh vote that's a smart calculator step
by POTUS uh Putin must know he will be
held accountable for aggression against
Ukraine and the united states will honor
our commitment to our NATO allies this
and and this is the craziest [__]
part about all of it is that the last
president United States [__] all over
NATO and and to help
Vladimir Putin his [__] little vladie
daddy and a lot of people uh you know uh
in the Republican Party especially
especially those ones who went to Moscow
on the fourth of July uh several years
ago I mean I don't know if that's like
an annual thing that they're going to go
celebrate our day of independence with
uh Putin but you know it seems like
might it might be an annual thing but
the fact of the matter is is you can't
you can't
uh you can't
use the sanctions right because I
apparently there's other technology uh
cell phone technology and other AI
technology that the United States is
kind of amplifying saying hey we'll use
this [__] to take you down uh we're
gonna lock up your [__] [__] and I
think your Communications which which
will damage them badly but I think these
sanctions are some of the sanctions that
will [__] [__] parts of their
economy but you can't do that before he
does something right like you can't it's
not Minority Report it really [__]
isn't like you cannot [__] go after
Putin yeah if I if I had some precogs
you know predict in the future great you
know that'd be awesome however if we
preemptively move toward this to say
like oh we're gonna
stop
anything from happening like we're we're
going to dissolve the tension by causing
tension it's like no that's not how that
works right and I would say that even if
Trump was still president right now
there would be two outcomes one uh
uh he would just go full blast in
two
um he would say he had negotiated some
deal with Putin only knowing that there
was some like
back room Shenanigans happening of like
some you know
stuff between sexually non-sexually
between Putin and Trump but letting him
say like okay listen like I won't you
know I won't look if you kind of you
know go in through Ukraine and start
[__] some people up like kind of
low-key
why me I mean the the fact that I think
you're right but the fact of the matter
is is that that you if you use the
sanction the power that you're going to
use as the deterrence once it happens
before it happens the deterrence is to
show them hey we will use [__] Force
if you use force and here's the
sanctions we're gonna put on
um here's you talk about [__]
cokehead booger sugar Junior oh boy Ron
says Hunter Biden apparently causing
Putin to threaten and The Invasion
Ukraine according to this geopolitical
genius right like we're going to take
advice from this dumb [__] yeah
on Geo political issues the guy that is
obsessed with Hunter Biden
I honestly don't know if that uh if that
like
um
that obsession is like it's clearly not
healthy but that Obsession that he has
towards Hunter if that's like him just
like yearning for like uh relationship
with a father and a son right because
Joe Biden no I mean hunter Biden is kind
of a [__] up right right yeah like yeah
we don't admit that he's kind of a [__]
up I mean I'm not I'm not gonna say you
know he's not that that's the reason why
he's not a part of the administration or
he's not like on White House calls and
he's not [__] negotiating deals
overseas in these countries and he's not
trying to bang up the United States he
is a fuck-up sure whatever but but I'll
read it here we'll we'll it Don JR says
will It ultimately be Hunters lucrative
Hunter's lucrative and shady as [__]
business dealings in Ukraine that gets
us into war with Russia what in the
actual [__] does any of that mean now
this guy now either is completely
[__] unaware of who Vladimir Putin is
and what his goal is or he he really is
like you said completely [__]
obsessed with Hunter Biden because even
though Hunter Biden is a complete [__]
up complete [__] up he's not part of the
administration his dad still loves him
like he still loves his son and I don't
know if that's the jealousy there like
he's making a jelly sandwich and he just
he's fine I think I think he is I think
it's him looking at like ever because
like if you look at the commentary
online like people [__] on uh
uh don Jr because like oh you know my
daddy doesn't love me right or he's like
you know face down in a in a in a pile
of Coke or he's
ranting about something random or you
know he's obsessively like talking about
Hunter but if you look at all the things
that are going on
the only thing he has that he can attach
his name to outside of just a [__] name
that is Trump is Hunter Biden right like
he's writing the coattails
well like he's writing the coattails and
pulling down Hunter Biden at the same
time right like he's pulling it down to
say that Hunter is this this [__] up
which again we all know no one said it
wasn't true right right but the
difference is he wasn't in a position of
Power with the administration the
difference is he has a father who cares
for him the difference is
uh Hunter has [__] up and you know has
attempted like an addict to make moves
to bettering himself for the future
right you know the other big difference
between [__] Hunter Biden and
cokehead booger sugar junior Here Don Jr
here's the biggest difference us
Democrats aren't [__] lined up around
the block to go watch Hunter Biden talk
we're not lined up around the block to
go get his [__] autograph and take a
[__] picture and pay you three
thousand dollars to take a picture with
the [__] Hunter Biden has no
room in politics because that's he's he
just happens to be he just happens to be
the president United States son who's
done some [__] up [__] he's got
problems everybody's got [__]
problems right Don Jr you dumb
[__] and by the way the shady
as [__] business dealings oh my God
the projection there is the other the
other side of it too is uh
and I I tweeted this yesterday is like
it was covered in December those email
like the whole like Q Anon leaks that
were happening right and you had uh Lynn
wood who leaked the emails of uh Tucker
Carlson's like I don't know oh yeah he
was trying to get Hunter Biden to write
his son uh right and so yesterday you
know yesterday yeah exactly and
yesterday I tweeted I was like oh you
know what's not in Hunter Biden's or you
know what is on Hunter Biden's laptop
emails from Tucker Carlson asking to
help his son Buckley get into Georgetown
by writing a letter of recommendation
right and some people were like
wait what like some people had not even
heard of this before which I was like I
guess it was covered in December and
then kind of just like washed over but
some people were like oh I didn't know
this happened some people like oh yeah
right and then as soon as I I linked it
they're like oh my bad and then some
other people were just like yeah that's
fake news and it's like
all right man you know I don't really
care all I'm telling you is what's true
like he asked for it and then Hunter
Biden was like sure I'll help your son
out and did a nice thing and then to a
person you know like whatever the
timeline was but to the person that is
just like actively [__] on
Hunter all the time which is Tucker
Carlson and using his Spotlight on using
his yeah Spotlight on Fox News to just
[__] on someone's reputation who already
has been [__] on and is living a you
know a street life because he's an
addict but here's the thing we get to
the point here like that that Ron's
making is this is the guy that these
[__] boneheads out there are
listening to on Facebook live or
wherever the [__] that is that he's
doing his coked out rants right and and
this tweet here that he has that he's
somehow the [__] expert on
geopolitical [__] um uh war with
Putin and Russia what the [__] are I
mean because that's that's the the the
thing here we're in the Putin thread he
was Putin was trending earlier of course
um but I want to see if I can find
um and and maybe we'll come across all
of those kids on the Trump side all
think that they are uh worthy of holding
positions the one clip that will always
make me laugh probably for the end of
time is when Ivanka came up to the other
world leaders
um
it was uh
uh who's it Germany and I forget who
else was there but it was a circle of I
think it was mainly women but there's a
clip of her she walks up and she like
tries to throw a couple lines into it
and she they [__] they just they just
do well here's another and here's
another one from dumb [__] junior he
says didn't anyone ever really did
anyone ever really think Putin would
ever be afraid of or respect Joe Biden
so here's the thing here's the thing
that is really [__] frightening about
these people is they actually think
Putin Putin testing how far Biden will
go is that Putin thinks that Biden is
weak no Putin is trying to see how
strong the United States military how
strong NATO and how strong the president
is he's trying to test how strong he is
he didn't try anything with with your
dad because he knew he had your dad in
his back [__] pocket that's why when
they had conversations asked anyone
right and it's like when they had
conversations they were like oh will you
release the tapes or talk about what you
talked about and like and like oh no we
won't we won't share that information
and it's like
what
what is going on that this is unheard of
that you would have a conversation with
a foreign entity and then just like not
divulge information or you're like oh
maybe they're recordings but they're no
longer there it's like why did you have
to cover up what you talked about why
why is there you know why is it so shady
that like what are your shady right
business deals right well and the
[__] absolute Bonkers ass [__] thing
here is that people are [__]
listening to this dumb [__] when he type
[__] out like this and they think he
knows what he's talking about listen we
on the left would never take anything
[__] seriously that Hunter by tweeted
if Hunter bite tweeted something would
you be like oh well that must be true
because he's he's Joe Biden's son and
Jill unless I hear it from the actual
elected official
if I hear anything from some sort of kin
or you know uh you know a spouse or
partner or whatever
I'm gonna take it as hearsay right uh
I'm not gonna believe that I'm getting
breaking news from the [__] son of
the President right like the fact that
you would assume like oh you know what
this person is breaking security
protocol to reveal some information
about something about the United States
to make us weak
what is that right so don Jr is I mean
let's just let's just admit it right
like Don Jr would sell out the company
for a dime bag okay oh [__] yeah he's
like oh let me get another hit would
totally do that no and again I'm not
making I'm not I'm I'm I do one because
I'm not making fun of addicts right now
I'm just making fun of Don Jr and how
he's a shitty person
he would sell you out in a second for
the next that that is how that mentality
works and that is why it's so [__]
dangerous that these people are
listening I mean look at look at this
[__] [__] here our allies Miss
president Trump you mean the NATO allies
that Trump told him them to go [__]
themselves I mean those allies you
people really are [__] bone-headed to
listen to this stupid [__] they wake up
every morning saying yeah that's a good
thing he's got here Wu-Tang says the guy
that should be in prison for ignoring
sexual abuse at Ohio State thinks Putin
and Kim Jong-un are American Allies
right what a what a [__] bonehead it
just I I can't you can't even [__]
it's hard to even put some of this [__]
in the words that that these now I mean
it's not surprising that they're saying
this dumb [__] right because obviously
they're on Putin's side because they
[__] hate America at this point I
mean we've seen people from the
Republican side chant on Putin and wear
merch that was like Pro Putin which is
insane on [__] Fox News like oh he's
so strong yeah yeah he's he's he's such
a man's man and all this [__] they're
like I want to see him bear chest on
that right right raw dog in that horse
you know it's like [__] Alpha cut
kind of [__] you know what I mean
they're Alpha Cooks that's what they are
you guys I don't know if you guys are
around for uh last Friday's bone end of
the week but we came up with the word
Alpha cook and we um I we may or may not
have uh secured alphacx.com
um and we're taking we may or may not be
taking suggestions on what to do with
Alpha cooks.com we got a few ideas of
our own but um uh you know may or may
not take some suggestions there let's
see if we can find I think this is it
here yes this is it this is the one I
want to play I want everyone to see this
um Lee McGowan does uh politics girl
podcast
uh she does these rants on Tick Tock and
she post them on Twitter
um and then she's associated with Midas
Touch they produce her podcasts and some
of her videos but um this video in
particular and she she's always spot on
she's always um knows exactly what she's
talking about she doesn't have to throw
a lot of data at you
um you know she just gets right straight
to the point and and really tells it how
it is but this video in particular if
you're confused about Russia and Ukraine
and what's going on it's very easy to
understand it after you watch this video
and the reason why is because [__]
this [__] is difficult to understand
because there's more than just than just
Joe Biden here
and jimin
right literally well there's that too
but literally literally the the at the
heart of this that you know Putin is
testing our president and the reason why
he's testing our president because he's
not sure kind of a go ahead how far
he'll go let's uh it's kind of before is
also kind of crazy to make the
assumption that some geopolitical issue
is only is only for the fact of one
person right right Putin it's like it's
only because Putin doesn't like uh or
doesn't respect Biden and it's like
Let's ignore all these other countries
and these other policies and politics
that have happened in the last you know
decades that have led up to this moment
dude it doesn't matter about that it's
only about this guy Biden right it's
like Joe Biden that's all it is right
well yeah well I mean it's Kimberly
Guilford holding up there yeah dude The
Best Is Yet To Come you know the best is
yet I wonder if she has those in the uh
the stack I don't know let's listen
let's listen to see what Lee says about
about this Ukraine mess okay so I'm not
an international expert and I don't
pretend to be but I'm going to try and
Broad Strokes what's going on right now
with the Ukraine Russia and America
backstory Putin was enraged when
anti-corruption pro-democracy
demonstrations led to the overthrow of
the Ukrainian government in 2014. like I
explained in far more detail on the
politics girl podcast rise of if you
want to check it out democracy is
contagious and if ukrainians could get
rid of their corrupt dictator what would
stop the Russian people from doing the
same it's one of the reasons Putin is so
hell-bent on putting the Ukraine back in
its place not only will it dissuade
other countries around him from getting
pro-democracy ideas but if he does it an
America NATO and the EU just let it
happen it'll prove on the world stage
that these Western Nations and democracy
itself no longer wield the power they
once did that in this new century no one
can really stop him and his allies from
taking and doing what they want and
believe me other nations will be
watching Nations like China who would be
very happy to do the same with Taiwan if
Russia can just take over a country and
install a pro-russian leader in the
Ukraine that's kind of a go-ahead for
other nations Ambitions so the US is in
a precarious position we can't instigate
a war with Russia there's no appetite in
this country for war we are already a
divided nation and with Republicans
behaving the way they are with Trump and
people like Tucker Carlson and Madison
cawthorne and the Republican Senators
who spent July 4th in Moscow being so
overtly pro-russia we can't unite the
country against a common enemy if half
of the country is rooting for the enemy
so our secretary of state Anthony
blinken is trying to use diplomacy and
give Putin an out to encourage him to
hold off invading the Ukraine the West
has threatened sanctions with profound
economic effects if Russia does invade
it has armed the Ukraine with weapons
and helicopters to defend themselves and
Americas in discussions with a number of
countries about stepping up production
of gas to our European allies who are
deeply worried that if Russia invades
there's going to be a massive gas
shortage because Russia provides Europe
with 40 of its gas supply there are
people in America namely Republicans
calling for us to implement the
sanctions now to take the first shot
thinking that it will show strength this
is a really good analogy that she gives
here
if you trigger them before they are
aggressive you lose the deterrent effect
it's like grounding your kid before he
has the party you have to threaten the
grounding and hope he doesn't have the
part also this idea that it's called
diplomacy is telling us to be the
aggressors begs the question of whose
side they're on if we do something
before they do something oh they've been
LARPing for [__] Russians for years
now is hoping for the best but preparing
for the worst expecting Russia to be
aggressive without starting the conflict
ourselves which I believe is the most
prudent step at this time
does that make sense
perfect perfect uh explanation of it in
in under three minutes
um Lee always delivers uh in that
situation in her kitchen which is
completely unbelievable that that we're
in a situation in our country with the
media and everything uh to explain this
to people that a person in her kitchen
who's a brilliant individual can do a
better job explaining what the hell is
going on to people in under three
minutes then the media could ever
[__] dream of so you have to go
follow uh podcast all right excuse me
for political uh politics girls podcast
Jesus
um and and actually and actually listen
to her podcast she does it every I think
it's every Tuesday and then it drops I
usually listen to it on YouTube
um but you can I think download it
anywhere you get your podcast but also
follow politics girl lead because um it
uh she's spot on she she makes the
arguments she doesn't need a lot of
[__] data and encyclopedias to throw
at you right like out the facts the way
they need to be laid out so and and Lee
if you're listening
we'd love to we love to have you on the
show um yeah and get your take on things
me and Gabe like to do interviews
um and we like to play trivia so if you
like to play trivia you know if uh
here's here's uh here's the link to the
podcast I think the one that she was
talking about autocracy which is a
[__] excellent Episode by the way
um I've listened to this one and she's
talking about how
um it's not just the right but it's the
left two and the slow walk to autocracy
can happen if we're not careful so we
got to be pro-democracy not pro
autocracy here
um which I think is important so and I
think you you got to run Gabe right yeah
I gotta go okay okay well let's go to a
break and then I'll I'll be right back
after this message
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
foreign
podcast Wednesdays at 4 pm Eastern 3 P.M
Central watch live on YouTube on Twitter
and twitch download on Apple and Spotify
now here's Tony
[Music]
well obviously we have to change a
little bit of our sound there because
that's an old old time three central
four Eastern you guys know that we're
two hours every single weekday Now noon
Eastern 11 Central right here on YouTube
Twitter twitch we had some comments
coming in about politics girl in the
last uh section they absolutely you guys
love politics girl I think MJ's saying
oh my God that would be amazing for Lee
to come on the show I absolutely would
have Leon any time she wanted to talk
about any subject that she'd want to
talk about
um I'd love I'd love to see Lee in the
[__] em attitude in the
um just to get her raw opinion on things
and and hear her rip on these people
because she does an excellent excellent
job
um yep get politics girl on yeah that I
absolutely she's welcome right now she's
listening I'll send you a link she can
come right on right now but um moving
forward there is some breaking news here
breaking news on the Tony Michaels
podcast on the shitless Roundup Sarah
Payne has reported tested positive for
covid-19 and it's going to delay the
start of the defamation suit against the
New York Times
um the the uh so today uh
they were supposed to start the
defamation suit about the New York Times
I guess had written an article several
years after the shooting where Gabby
Giffords was almost killed and several
people were killed in that mass shooting
uh but the when when New York Times ran
an article and used that as an analogy
for another event and I think it had to
do with the ski Steve scalise shooting
you guys remember the the maniac that
came in with the gun and was firing at
people playing baseball they happened to
be politicians that was his aim and he
hit Steve scalise and Steve scalise was
in the hospital and had to recover
apparently the New York Times are
written an article and used used the the
Arizona shooting where Gabby Giffords
was shot as an analogy to the one with
Steve scalise
so
that is part of the defamation suit
that's happening um that is a story in
and of itself
um
but the
um here's another breaking anti-vaxxer
Sarah Palin assisted positive for covid
thoughts oh I got a lot of [__]
thoughts on this
um number one
um I'm not so sure that she's not
vaccinated just because they say they're
not vaccinated doesn't mean they're not
vaccinated we've seen this time and time
again with these [__] we've
seen this with this [__] rally this
weekend this [__] mandate rally
where these these [__] idiots who are
vaccinated are telling people not to get
vaccinated
I mean I'm not going to put a past Sarah
Palin to be so [__] stupid that she
wouldn't get vaccinated right I mean
come on she's she's kind of a [__]
right kinda
I mean I'm [__] being nice
I'm being really [__] nice
but here's the thing with with Sarah
Palin
um not being vaccinated is that you have
this situation now where not on not not
only is this [__] story about the
defamation suit gonna happen and now
there's gonna be this big [__]
argument about her testing positive for
covet well here's the thing here's the
thing
go get vaccinated dumb [__] and
you know the the anti-vaxx rally are not
anti-backed it was an it they tried to
pin it up
um they tried to pin it up as an
anti-mandate right so they moved the
goal post again and again oh what's mayo
say
Sarah Palin has coveted and I'm out of
[__] the game
oh I lost my [__] on Sarah Palin
in 2008
you guys remember that that's oh my God
that seems like [__] so long ago
when the Katie Couric moment when Katie
Couric just asked her what she reads and
she's like everything I read everything
all of it every [__] thing that is
readable I read it get the [__] out of
here
um
Let's see we got some comments we're
going in
um
Tony says Capital police safe scalise
sorry ass yeah they did
um the security detail at there that was
at the game saved a lot of those folks
um not just Republicans but Democrats
uh Caitlyn says the judge today said of
course she isn't vaccinated
is that an actual quote I haven't read
the story yet I just seen the breaking
news as we were on the break I was going
to go the Sarah Palin thread and uh
about the defamation suit and Bam she's
got coveted
um so
I guess Sarah really wants to meet
meatloaf well you know VIP pass yeah I
mean maybe maybe
maybe maybe they do
um but back to the not the coveted part
because we'll get to that the the
defamation suit part
um
with them
I'm getting sidetracked by jokes here
Sarah Palin is giving live updates on
Ukraine from her front porch you
remember this [__] she could see Russia
from her house
um this is the dumb [__]
that we have to deal with with these
people
um and so it's not surprising that she's
contracted coven you think if she would
had such a [__] important case she
would make sure that she was vaccinated
she would make sure that she was making
that not being around a lot of people
that where she could contract coven and
also trying to isolate to a certain
degree so she didn't get it that way she
could get her ass into court with this
defamation suit which really honestly
this defamation suit is uh really really
um trying to go after the Free Press
really hard and whatever the outcome of
this is going to be significant
um as insignificant as Sarah Palin is
this case is defamation lawsuit with the
New York Times is super important
because basically
what they're wanting to do in the
defamation case
is uh restrict the Free Press from
making analogies right I mean that's you
know now of course the New York Times in
the um
in in in in the time at that time when
they released the article that the
defamation is about they backtrack they
change the story they released an
apology almost immediately when they
realized that it might not have been a
great analogy right
um and of course you know that's
something that happens in publishing you
know not that there's an excuse for for
every single time something happens but
that appears to be what has happened and
evidence here and they're going to have
to convince a jury that the New York
Times was malicious in this even though
after immediately after realizing what
had happened with the analogy they'd
backtrack but you know so that's the
definition but the but the outcome of
this defamation suit could be have a
very significant impact
on how the media would write stories and
how people would talk about stories I
mean that's not gonna affect me [__]
them I don't give a [__] come after me
[__] them
um
let's see what else do we have here
um Smite another one of our favorites if
the next covet variant is named duh oh
[__] this is gonna be good it's very
likely that Sheriff's patience here
uh [__] the duh variant well you know I
call the Omicron I call the Oman the
Omicron Baron the [__] variant because
that's that's what it is I mean you've
seen these [__] morons go to
Washington DC yesterday right if you
guys see this where they went um to stop
the mandates or some [__] they don't
even know what the [__] mandates are
they again they don't have dictionaries
anymore apparently mandate is a shorter
word than than requirement which it is a
the the vaccine mandates that they're
talking about is vaccine requirements
it's a requirement meaning like if you
want to do something you have are
required to do something else like
you're like all the time all the [__]
time when you want to do something like
if you want to go into a liquor store
and buy you know a couple this a Jack
Daniels
you know to have a nice weekend or
whatever
they might require you to get out your
[__] ID to prove that you're 21 right
it's a requirement right they might
require you to do that
what in the [__] don't you people
understand about this now if your dumb
ass decides that either you're not 21 or
that you decide I'm not going to show my
[__] ID [__] you oh you want to
require me to show my ID yeah I do well
I'm not doing it well guess how many
[__] fifths of Jack Daniels you're
gonna get not [__] one
you [__] people are deciding this
[__] you're choosing your you're using
your [__] Liberty that our
constitution grants you not to get
vaccinated that's a thing that's
happening
you are using your Liberty
with the freedoms and the rights that
the constitution grants you not to get
vaccinated but that doesn't mean you get
to do whatever the [__] you want if if
somewhere has a [__] vaccine
requirement whether it be a job whether
it be a a venue that you're going to
attending whatever it is a a type of
transportation that you have to get on
to use you're making that [__] Choice
it's not a mandate a mandate
a mandate is when they [__] hold you
down on the ground and put the vaccine
in you that's a [__] mandate what you
people are protesting are requirements
you people want to be oppressed so
[__] bad you so so want to be [__]
oppressed
even Robert Kennedy Jr which we can play
a clip of it [__] gets on stage and
compares the vaccine requirements to to
[__] the Holocaust again with this
[__]
again
[Laughter]
I hear you now you guys got some
comments going here no shirts no shoes
no service don't tread on me they're
[__] snowflakes they really are uh
Kalyn says vaccine blowtards
um freedoms vaccine blow darts oh [__]
yeah we shouldn't give the CDC any ideas
really we shouldn't but you know because
I I'm not always I'm not always I'm not
always for a tyrannical tyranny uh
vaccine blow dart sound [__] but here's
the point with the with the rally that
they had this weekend what they're
bitching about is a requirement that
they have chose not to [__] comply to
right whether it be in their job whether
it be in their Community to go to a
venue a church a school whatever
whatever the [__] it is you are using
your freedoms and rights at our
constitution grants you to give you the
Liberty to make the choice not to be
vaccinated fine that's what you want to
do great the rest of us want you to get
vaccinated so we don't have to keep
stuffing the [__] hospitals full of
sick [__] and and continuing to
strain our health care System where
people who who have other medical
ailments that need to be treated whether
it be heart attack stroke and accident
that need treatment can get [__]
treatment and you [__] boneheads
aren't piling up the goddamn hospitals
these [__] doctors and nurses are
tired of treating your dumb asses when
they don't have to
you understand that right the reason why
doctors and nurses are so [__] pissed
off
is because it doesn't have to be this
way it really doesn't
vaccinated people
are not dying from the coronavirus
vaccinated people are not being
hospitalized from the coronavirus
vaccinated people by a large Martian
aren't even Contracting the coronavirus
and if you [__] would do your
[__] civic duty and be a goddamn
Patriot and protect the rest of your
community whether it be your [__]
school your [__] Church your [__]
workplace whatever what the [__] ever it
is
if you were a [__] Patriot and you
loved your [__] country and you
wanted to help your community so that
you weren't spreading around sickness
and stuffing up our [__] hospitals so
these doctors and nurses don't have to
keep taking care of your dumb asses
and watching you [__] die
go get [__] vaccinated or just stay
your [__] ass at home if you're so
[__] hell-bent on how bad the vaccine
is and the people that you're seeking
treatment from their solution is for
your stupid [__] dumbass to go get
vaccinated stop going and asking them
for medical advice
stop it stay at home listen to Joe
Rogan's podcast and do what he says
once you contract covid do that eat the
eat the [__] cat turds drink the piss
take the [__] horse dewormer
whatever the [__] regiment that you get
from Joe Rogan's podcast because that's
obviously where you want to get your
[__] medical advice
go do that
stop wanting the both sides of the fence
thing well I don't want to get
vaccinated and I'm not going to listen
to the professionals that tell me to get
vaccinated and why they're telling me
they get vaccinated oh I got covered oh
I'm sick oh God I need the hospital I'm
gonna go to the hospital and seek advice
from the people I wasn't seeking advice
from in the first place
I'm with Howard Stern here
I'm not wishing death upon anyone
but when you jump off a [__] Bridge
without tying the bungee cord correctly
or even tying it on your feet at all
thinking that you're gonna survive that
bungee jump you are stupid [__]
and that's what that's what a certain
population of our country is doing
is they're going to the edge of the
[__] bridge to go bungee jumping
and they got a choice they're either
going to let the guy who's been tying
[__] bungee cords on people's [__]
ankles for decades and decades and
decades
and never had one smash their heads on
the Rocks below
are you gonna let Joe Rogan tie your
[__] bungee cord not huh what are you
gonna do dumb [__]
what are you gonna do
so you choose you choose but don't be
bitching and moaning and complaining
once you make your [__] choice you
[__] white privileged little [__]
God damn I'm sick and [__] tired two
[__] years we've been doing this [__]
and then they want to say oh oh oh I'm
done with coven done with coven
done the only reason why we're not done
with covet is because you're stupid
asses
that's the only reason why we're not
done with covid if Elixir if the
majority of the population in this
country was fully [__] vaccinated
to the extent that they could be
vaccinated at this point
in the timeline in this crazy [__]
stupid timeline that we're in
yes people would still be getting
covered people would still have to stay
home from work because they were sick
but the hospitals wouldn't be packed
full
it's a [__] unnecessary thing that
we're doing to not only the Health Care
community
but our our communities in general and
the economy you dumb [__]
everyone bitching why are you closing
schools cause there's no one who can
teach they're all sick
I have grown up and I remember being in
a world where a public school if there
was so much [__] flu and there's too
many teachers sick that they had to
close the school down you want to
compare to the flu do that do it
it really is [__] bone-headed type
[__]
and Sarah Palin getting a [__]
covid-19 and Contracting covid-19 not
only as a surprise but does not bring a
[__] tear to my eye
don't give two [__] I don't care she's
vaccinated or not she claims to be
unvaccinated but I wouldn't be surprised
if that [__] [__] is vaccinated
because that's what these bastards do is
they go around and they [__] try to
sow chaos by making sure that this
country remains sick they want a reason
to blame the libs on some [__]
some [__] dumbass [__] it's
ridiculous
needs to [__] stop so if you want a
mandate [__] I say if we if they want a
mandate we [__] give it to him
that's what we should do if they want a
[__] real mandate because what you're
talking about isn't a mandate you dumb
[__] it's a goddamn requirement
you're making the choice not to get
vaccinated and you can't do the [__] you
want to do so you're being a [__]
Snowflake and whining and crying and
bitching about it get the [__] out of
here with that goddamn [__]
Amy one of our favorite here says Sarah
Palin misses Over My Dead Body that I
have to get vaccinated has covered
covers response here's your chance
Over My Dead Body here's your [__]
chance
Sarah
you can't lipstick this pig
hmm
I wonder I wonder how tough she thinks
she is with coven we'll see we'll see
all right let's go back to the Tweety
tweets and the trendy Trends we are we
are an hour and we are 38 minutes into
the second hour this is our first two
hour two hour show official uh Tony
Michaels podcast let me explain how
that's gonna work how it's different
than just a [__] list Roundup because
we've been doing the shitless Roundup
today
uh and and we'll continue to do the [__]
list Roundup inside the Tony Michaels
podcast but there's a couple things that
are going to change everyone noticed
that that uh YouTube is open it's open
for business during the shitless Roundup
you know we've always just streamed the
shitless Roundup on Twitch and Twitter
and if you wanted to comment get your
comment in the show you had to go over
to Twitch uh to get your comments in the
show but today is the first day that
we're on YouTube so now you can go over
and comment on YouTube it's live we're
live on YouTube broadcasting right now
the other the other difference between
uh the [__] list Roundup before and the
[__] list Roundup now is all the people
that download the podcast on the podcast
directory so Apple podcast Spotify uh
Google podcast all those directories the
show The Daily Show the two-hour show is
going to be on those directories every
single day every one of them every
weekday
now of course you know it's a live show
so we have to
um after the show here we download the
audio and then we upload it to all the
directories and then I'll you know I'll
tweet out the links and stuff like that
but go over to the directors your
favorite directory you'd rather be uh
Apple Spotify Google go wherever you get
your the listen to the Tony Michaels
podcast these episodes will be
on
on those directories because this is
episode 60. can you believe that we're
at episode 60 already now we're going to
increase in episodes really quickly here
because we're going to be doing five
episodes a week
every single weekday noon Eastern 11
Central YouTube Twitter twitch it'll
also go up on all all
the directories after we're done
recording
um so stay tuned to that and and we'll
we'll get you know stay stay in the
tubes of you go over on Twitch the
Tweety tweets and trendy trends uh no
matter where you're watching
and stay tuned okay let's let's go down
and see what else um
what else we had because I had a few
other subjects I believe I wanted to
talk about
um the affirmative action I didn't get
to that we didn't get to Julian Assange
yet um we did the Don Jr uh we did uh
Russia Sarah Palin okay so let's see if
affirmative action yes it is still it is
still trending let's see what this is I
have not looked to see what this is the
Wall Street Journal reporting here the
Supreme Court agreed to consider
challenges
uh to reach constant submissions
policies at Harvard and the University
of North Carolina giving justices a
platform to potentially overrule Decades
of President allowing affirmative action
higher education
so it looks like let's see what the
Associated Press is I'll give credit
because I read it there on the um Wall
Street Journal but I'm not always
trustworthy of the Wall Street Journal
you're going to watch them Associated
Press the Supreme Court will hear
lawsuits claiming that Harvard and the
University of North Carolina
discriminate against Asian American
applicants a decision against the
schools could mean the end of
affirmative action in college admissions
um this is very interesting
I would like to uh see if we could get
someone on to talk about this
um
affirmative action is kind of a really
complicated thing
um when you're talking about when you're
talking especially when you're talking
about college admissions now it's pretty
simple
um as far as you know trying to break it
down in that uh the affirmative action
what it does is it allows people who who
wouldn't normally be able to work their
way into a College admissions office to
get in there to get their due right to
get their due
um MJ says episode 5 50 feels like
yesterday oh it's gonna these episodes
are gonna tick by so fast
so fast can you drop the link in Twitter
to the podcast downloads yeah you just
go to just go to the Tony michaels.com
just go to the Tony michaels.com it's at
the top of the the uh the Twitter pages
and then when you go to the Tony
michaels.com that's got a Spotify Apple
I believe Google's on there the YouTube
channel twitch
um you can also go to
podcast.thetonymichaels.com and um
that'll that'll get you there you can
download the podcast there as well but
just go to your favorite directory and
just search the Tony Michaels pod or the
Tony Michaels podcast and that [__] will
pop up
um wherever you're at so the Tony
michaels.com or just click the link in
the bio
um again back to this affirmative action
again I haven't read anything on this
case
um
of exactly what's going to happen here
what this is
um
Barbara is pretty sure that you're going
to say goodbye to affirmative action in
2023 and this is this is why you got to
remember this is why it was so important
for these evangelicals
um to to actually get
in front of
um in front of the well I get on the
federal societies list and to make sure
that's why they were so desperate to put
uh what's her what's her [__] name
um on on the Supreme Court very last
minute because it wasn't just about
abortion it was about banging up
people's Liberties in this country
that's what they want they want to take
away your [__] Liberty the Supreme
Court has made sure that the
constitution affords Liberties to all
Americans
and now we're not there you know we're
not a full Equity inequality yet that's
why we got to keep fighting
we know that we know that for sure and I
don't know that you know full equity and
equality ever is 100 achievable I mean
I'd like to dream that that is the case
but we must keep fighting until we reach
that moment
um it might be Generations past us but
we have to give them the momentum to
keep fighting
but these fascists want to tear down our
liberties
duty to warn says Supreme Court
announced Monday that it will once again
look at whether universities may
consider the race of applicants when
trying to build diverse student bodies
an ominous development for those who say
there is a continuing need for
affirmative action in higher education I
believe there is actually a need for uh
affirmative action in this day and age
when we have these [__] bigots
running around trying to bang up all of
our liberties I mean look what they're
trying to do with our right to vote
and you don't you don't think that
they'll [__] squash something as far
as as as what they consider minuscule as
higher education and emissions
absolutely they will they don't want
[__] they don't want people of color
to be educated they don't want people of
color to vote they don't want people of
color and in the University Systems
you know learning things getting smart
being able to advance their lives in
society you know they might they might
become like you know Vice President of
the United States or something then what
the [__] would they do they might become
the governor of [__] Georgia then
what the [__] would they do huh then
what what the [__] would they do if they
had people of color running around being
Governors and presidents and all that
kind of [__] boy they really be [__]
wouldn't they that's that's the point
that's why they [__] hate democracy
they [__] hate democracy they [__]
hate it that's why they don't want they
they don't want liberals especially
um members of the people and people of
color in those communities to vote
I've been saying this for [__] weeks
and weeks Georgia has been blue for
years it didn't just turn blue George's
Texas is blue for [__] sake I would
bet I would bet that Alabama is [__]
blue they voted for Doug Jones
now I mean yeah did did Doug Jones
ultimately lose well that's because
the blue voters in Alabama decided that
uh maybe it's not as maybe it's not as
blue as we thought that's why we gotta
have some [__] Gusto here we have to
stay pissed we have to go [__] vote
we have to have some strategic goddamn
outrage
we had Rachel bickhoffer on a couple
weeks ago you guys need to go watch that
interview as well if you're not
subscribed to the YouTube channel you
should and you must go watch that
interview with Rachel we posted that
individually she talks about the
Strategic outrage and how Democrats need
to take take off the [__] boxing
gloves and fight this fight stop [__]
pussy-footing around
stop being such goddamn snowflakes we
need to fight this fight where they want
to fight it and that's democracy they
[__] hate democracy they want to tear
it down and we want to fight for it so
let's [__] fight for it
let's get some Gusto let's stay pissed
let's go [__] vote and I don't just
mean marking a ballot
I mean tearing these people apart in
these campaigns pitting them against
each other I'm talking about getting
activated in your county your County
Democratic party Google it call them go
get activated get engaged rather be
making phone calls or or text messaging
or whatever the case is if you got money
they're gonna need money that's right
Democrats you got to give up a little
bit of your wallet to make sure that
these candidates have money that's the
other [__] thing that Democrats get
in their head is that oh wow well
campaigns are funded by billionaires
well all the billionaires are starting
to appear to be fascist so we need to
[__] gather up a little bit of our
change to help fight these [__]
we got to do it we have to do it uh Yoda
says
Rachel bickhoffers amazeballs yes she is
Rachel knows
um and again go watch that interview go
follow Rachel on Twitter as well
um but go watch the interview on the
YouTube channel you'll know what I'm
talking about especially the second half
after trivia
it's worth a watch go watch it now let's
see here let's um
let's go back I want to let's see what
other subject were 48 minutes in the out
of the Julian Assange thing I want to
see if we can touch on that as well
let's see what else we got do we got
anything else ergon is trending Kevin
McCarthy let's skip in here real quick
before we go the Julian Assange
um Scott says speaker Pelosi just beat
Kevin McCarthy again again and again and
again and again and again this isn't
news
um this time via Supreme Court rejected
his challenge to remote vote oh yeah I
think um
Kevin McCarthy was challenging the
Supreme Court that they couldn't vote by
proxy which is really [__]
bone-headed because there's a [__] ton
of [__] Republicans that vote by
proxy why he wanted this fight he
thought this fight was a good one to
have I don't know but it's completely up
in uh upon the speaker in the house
rules
um to have vote by proxy so good luck
Kevin you [__] idiot let's see what
Kyle says official reporting the Supreme
Court has denied Republican Kevin
McCarthy's challenge
to speaker Pelosi's proxy voting
protocols put in place during the
pandemic
yeah so again they had rule changes
because of the pandemic and that's what
the house can do they can change rules
on proxy voting they can do that just
like just like the Senate can change the
rule on the filibuster they can change
it to the way it used to be where your
hat your ass has to stand there and talk
the whole [__] time not this
[__] where you don't have to do that
where you can just phone it in you know
if they don't want to phone in the proxy
vote in the house maybe they shouldn't
want to phone in the goddamn filibuster
okay let's see what else Don Jr is still
trending now let's go to the trends
trendy Trends the Tweety tweets here
Sarah Palin Eastern Europe we went
through those I'm trying to get through
the stuff today we got a lot of stuff
and we missed some of it uh from the
weekend but we'll probably get to some
of it tomorrow you know we missed the
Aaron Rodgers thing I really wanted to
do the Aaron Rodgers thing there's a lot
of good videos on Aaron Rodgers a lot of
digging on Aaron Rodgers and you know
how that goes we have to do that
um NASDAQ
um is falling
um Don Jr
um let's see is is there something else
no that's the video where is the Julian
assigned the Julian Assange story gets
buried
um basically what has happened with
Julian Assange
is that
um I'm on the wrong [__] one
let's see here
let's see
sorry about that
technical difficulties you know how I
can go okay let's let's go to the Julian
Assange
um
let's see if we can make this work here
let's go on the Julian Assange
oh dude there we go okay so here we are
doing Assange you guys know uh Joanna
Sanchez appealed his extradition he was
going to be extradited to the United
States
for some of the stuff that he's done
with Wikileaks
um and they have shown that he can
appeal this decision of extradition to
the Supreme Court in UK
um which is a pretty big development in
the case of the extradition of Joe and
Assange
um
and of course if you look at this Jesus
Christ it's just Wikileaks is all over
it's all over this thing you know
Wikileaks used to have a purpose I guess
but now the purpose is only to save you
and your sanja's ass
um or you know to propagate Russian you
know Russian propaganda
um here's the New York Times headline
breaking news the WikiLeaks founder
Julian Assange can appeal the decision
to allow his extradition to the U.S to
face charges on the Espionage Act in
connection with obtaining and Publishing
secret government dockets documents a
British Court ruled
um so this doesn't mean that he can't
still be charged it's just he's
challenging his extradition here so we
will um
you'll stay on top of that story I'm I'm
not sure when this is supposed to happen
um
of course there's a lot of people
LARPing for [__] doing the sanj
which you know I I at some point in
history right Julian Assange had a
decent purpose to make sure that people
knew things
but it was only when he became it became
irrelevant and started to try to make
himself relevant by by uh
um propagating
Russian propaganda and really trying to
work for Russia to bang up democracy is
the problem I have with this
[__]
it is a real [__] problem
[Music]
oh Midas Lisa's here hey minus Lisa how
are you
thanks for joining us you can go over to
YouTube or you can keep chatting and
twitch either way either way don't worry
about being late either because here's
the thing
here's the thing if you show up late
it's recorded on YouTube Twitter twitch
you can always go back and re-watch it
the other thing that's going to be
different now now that we're on two
hours every single weekday is you can
actually go listen to the podcast on the
podcast directory so the [__] list
Roundup is now going to be on the
podcast directories of course I am not
magical so what I have to do what I have
to do is I actually have to you know
like download it and then put it up
because I can't you know post it while
we're recording on the podcast
directories unfortunately or I would
like if I I wish there was like a radio
app and we could have that would
broadcast out you know you could listen
to it on there live but you know I don't
know we'll figure that out
uh who else is bored by Julian is lounge
[__] this guy [__] this gay okay let's
make sure one last time we don't have
any breaking news here uh because we are
54 54 minutes into the second hour
thanks for joining us for the first two
hour
uh Tony Michaels podcast with the [__]
list Roundup you've seen and Gabe came
in today
um we're supposed to have an interview
this week I think we're supposed to
record tomorrow so hopefully we'll have
that interview ready for you at
Wednesday or Thursday uh to play for you
here on the show
um that's how that's going to work from
now on is uh you know we'll do the
shitless Roundup in the um in the uh in
the first hour and then do the podcast
stuff in the second hours or interviews
and stuff like that
um oh hey Midas Lisa is over here now
now on YouTube hey you're on YouTube
yeah so so follow us um on Twitch
YouTube subscribe to the YouTube channel
um you know go follow us um at the Tony
Michaels POD at D Tony Michaels and I am
Gabe Sanchez over on Twitter to keep up
with all that stuff
um keep following us on Twitch too don't
don't don't think the twitch doesn't
serve a purpose over there and we got a
lot of people there's a lot of trolls
over there if you guys want to go mess
with the trolls remember that uh but uh
um we're gonna try to
we're gonna try to do this every single
weekday noon Eastern 11 Central two
hours
um so it's gonna format a little bit
different
but it's still going to have the same
good old shitless Roundup
and we're gonna throw in the podcast
stuff during the week as well so if we
have guests if we had Poppins if we have
um this or that we will play it here on
the Tony Michaels podcast during the
[__] list Roundup or or after it again
we got an interview this week that I'm
excited about but speaking of interviews
you should go watch the last two
interviews that we did they're on the
YouTube channel Rachel bitkoffer the
political strategist with strike back
she has such a good [__] plan for
strategic outrage because we have to
stay [__] pissed we have to go vote
because Democrats are going to be the
only ones that deliver here Republicans
all they want to do is destroy our
democracy Democrats deliver Republicans
destroy so stay pissed go [__] vote
have that strategic outrage go get
involved Collier County your county your
county party they'll direct you towards
those candidates that are in your that
are in your voting district they'll
direct you to who who you should who
who's who's a [__] you've seen these
ghost candidates that they're coming up
with these [__] Republicans running
as [__] as uh trying to trick
Democrats into voting for them yeah
they're going to do that kind of [__]
they're gonna do that [__] so you you
know we got to get we got to get in out
in front of this thing
so stay pissed go [__] vote and um
uh let's see one let's see if we got
anything else I just want to make sure I
feel like I'm missing something today
there was something that I missed we did
the Don Junior it must have been that
Robert um let's go do that real quick
before we head out the the Bobby Kennedy
Junior let's see Robert
Kennedy Jr there it is
it's [__] idiot
um
Ben has him here Ben Collins at the
anti-vaxx rally in DC RFK JR says that
in the future none of us can run and
none of us can hide
because Bill Gates Satellites and also
5G unlike all what the [__]
even even in Hitler's Germany you could
hide an attic like Anne Frank did oh God
damn this [__] guy let's let's let's
watch this file piece of [__]
you gotta watch this [__] you gotta know
what they're saying
a 1962 East Germany go hide in your
attic dumbass
go go hide in your [__] attic from
the vaccines go hide in your house like
let's say yeah sure do that
go hide
what with my father
and met people who had climbed the wall
and escaped so it was possible maybe I
truly but it was possible does he sound
like he has code what is that I I never
listened to this guy speak really
honestly and they're listening to speak
does he have coven he sounds like he's
really at a [__] breath or something
I don't know I'm just I'm just saying I
mean maybe that was a requirement for
the [__] rally that they had to have
they had to test positive for covet I
don't know today
the mechanisms are being put in place I
will make it none of us can run and none
of us can hide
the within five years we're going to see
000 low orbit satellites oh Jesus Christ
says his 65 000 that's why it's alone
5G
to harvest our data okay okay okay so
here's the thing I seen a [__] story
this week about these uh about uh uh
[__] Elon Musk wanting to put chips
in people's brains
uh actual billionaire saying I'm gonna
put a chip in your brain
to con I don't know what the [__] it's
supposed to do
make you as incel as Elon Musk I don't
know I don't know if it's like a [__]
Alpha cuck chip or something that goes
in your brain I don't know you're saying
but they have a billionaire touting that
they're gonna put chips in their brain
and hear these dumb [__] are
talking about satellites and stupid [__]
with the vaccine just go get vaccinated
we don't want people to get sick you
dumb [__]
all right until tomorrow noon Eastern 11
Central remember right here same time
same place Tony Michaels podcast we're
gonna do the [__] list Roundup every
single weekday two hours noon Eastern 11
Central YouTube Twitter twitch follow us
on YouTube go to Twitch if you want to
[__] with all the trolls
and then stay on Twitter if you want to
surf and do all that kind of stuff
until tomorrow I'll Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em